MANDY WAITE: So we're
going to be talking
to you about going
from data to meaning.
So effectively what this
means is taking data and doing
something useful with it.
Making it mean something to your
business, to your organization.
It's kind of a
step-by-step guide.
It's a walkthrough
of the steps you
would use to approach
a data problem.
And we use a specific
example during the talk
to illustrate this
and to highlight this.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is-- well, I don't
actually need this
because we're
presenting from there.
The first thing I need to
ask you is how many of you
have heard of Hadoop?
OK, so keep your hands up.
How many of you have built your
own personal Hadoop cluster?
OK, so not so many of you.
OK, so, it sounds like
fun though, doesn't it?
So, perhaps it's
something we should try.
Let's try building
a Hadoop cluster.
Can we switch to the demos,
switch to the machine?
Right, brilliant.
As in the best [? junior ?]
[? trial ?] with principles
of demos, we have some
things we've set up already.
We have a Compute Engine
virtual machine instance
that we've set up
to run this demo.
But that's pretty
much all we've done.
Well, actually we've also done
some configuration as well.
So, I have this
virtual machine here
which I'm going to SSH into.
And to do that, I'm
going to go my shell.
Everybody see that?
Yeah.
I think it should be good.
What I'm going to do is
SSH into this machine,
if I can find the
appropriate command.
So I'm using the command
line tool from our cloud SDK
to SSH into that machine.
And here we are.
It's a real Linux box.
We can do ps minus ef to
see what we've got running.
And what we'll do is
we'll cd to slash user.
That's bd, whoops.
I'm not very good
at typing either.
So, what I'm going to
do is run a script.
And we have some configuration
we've already done beforehand
on this.
Whoops, I really can't type.
So we're going to run this
command called bdutil, which
I'll talk about more briefly.
And for those of you who
have not heard of Hadoop,
we'll have a slide
afterwards that
will just kind of position that.
For those of you who have,
this could, hopefully,
be impressive.
And one think I want to do
actually first because I forgot
to do it earlier is change
my configuration file.
So, whoops.
I see the demo gods
are still favoring me
because I haven't
broken anything yet.
So, Hadoop is a
distributed system
for performing data processing.
And for that, you need
a number of workers.
And I'm going to
provide 20 workers.
So I'm going to
ask you to spin up
20 workers in my
Hadoop cluster for me.
So, what I do is-- I was
testing on smaller clusters
because I've been
having problems
with this particular demo.
And I've been using a small
size to make sure it works,
and I forgot to change it.
So that's my fault.
And .bdutil deploy.
That gives us a list of
our configuration options.
This is the
configuration that will
be used to build
our Hadoop cluster.
We have NUM_WORKERS 20,
that's what we just changed.
It's going to create a bunch of
Compute Engine virtual machines
to deploy Hadoop on, some more
information about our project,
our image that
we're going to use,
the zone we're going
to use, et cetera.
And a prefix we're going to
use for these virtual machines
is NYC just to prove it's real.
And as you can see, we don't
have any virtual machines
currently, apart
from the one we've
been using to do the setup.
So I'll say yes.
And it goes off now.
And it's effectively doing
a lot of asynchronous tasks
to create instances.
We have lots of machines,
workers, 20 of them,
that are going to come up.
And we have one name mode
server, a master server,
that will manage and coordinate
the whole of the Hadoop
cluster.
So that's doing that
in the background.
And that's going to take
a little while to finish.
But we can see, probably,
if we hit refresh.
Now the cloud console,
the developer's console,
doesn't refresh very often.
So you often have to go
into to enter a refresh.
And here we can see more
instances coming up.
There should be 20 of them.
OK.
Why is it doing that?
Now I'm puzzled.
OK, so this should
actually showed them
in various different
states of provisioning.
But it's actually showing
them all provisioned.
So we have 20 nodes there.
I think it's 20.
I don't see any missing.
But normally you
would see all of them.
And you would see some of
them will be in provisioned
and some of them
are up and ready.
The green tick here told me
that that's up and running.
We also have this nyc-nn, which
is our main node, our master
coordinator for
the whole cluster.
And I ought to discuss why.
Checking on the wrong thing.
So these are the instances
being provisioned.
So this one, nycdn-18,
is all being provisioned.
All the others are
already up and running.
The disks that will be used
by these virtual machine
are also being created as well.
I can go to the IP address
of the NameNode, click on it,
and I can simply
enable HTTP traffic
for that virtual machine.
We're going to need this.
This is our Hadoop master.
This is how we're going to
interface with the Hadoop
cluster later on.
So I click Apply on that.
And that will go off and do
something in the background.
And effectively
enable HTTP and HTTPS,
open those ports up
on that instance.
So because we don't have
any minions in this talk,
I thought we should have one.
So that's just an aside, though.
That's not really
key to this talk.
We do have minions
in the talk later.
I hope Julia has minions
in the next talk as well.
They're so cute.
Right, so can we go back
to the slides, please?
Unfortunately, this
kind of requires
going backwards and
forwards to check.
And because we're controlling
the size from there,
I can't quickly switch
backwards and forwards.
So we'll come back to
that Hadoop deployment
soon and see what it's doing.
So for those of you who
didn't know what Hadoop was,
Hadoop is an open source
implementation of Mapreduce.
Mapreduce is
effectively a mechanism
by which we can do
distributed computing.
It was invented by Google.
We published a white
paper back in 2003.
It consists of two main steps.
The first is a map step.
Effectively, this is performed
on small sets, small subsets
of the data that
you want to process.
And it's distributed across all
of these nodes in a cluster.
We saw, we created one
with 20 in this case.
And then all of the
output from these map jobs
are pushed into a
reduced job, in which we
can do other things as well.
This is the next part of
the phase of the Mapreduce.
In this case, we're going
to reduce the data set down.
The demo we're going to look
at later only has a map step.
And the reduce step
could, effectively,
be run across multiple
nodes as well.
Mapreduces can be run on both
structured and unstructured
data, and Hadoop, to give it
its full name, is Apache Hadoop
and has this nice
little elephant.
So, Hadoop itself has a file
system, a distributed file
system, that allows
you to support
this notion of distributing
subsets of the data
across a huge number
of nodes in a cluster.
And we only have
20 nodes, but you
could imagine a Hadoop
cluster with 1,000 nodes.
Somehow we had to distribute the
data across all of those nodes.
And the way Hadoop does that
is through a file system called
HDFS, which is its
own file system.
And Hadoop is completely
open source, by the way.
When we're running Hadoop
on Google Cloud Platform,
we have several managed data
services at our disposal,
including BigQuery, Datastore,
and Google Cloud Storage.
So what we want to
really be able to do
is store data in
those data services
and let Hadoop access the
data directly from them,
rather than creating a HDFS
file system on multiple nodes
and then copying
all the data around.
We want to do it in situ
within the data service
that we already have in place,
So we have these connectors,
we have a BigQuery connector,
a Cloud Storage connector,
and a Datastore connector.
bdutil is a very simple script.
It's effectively a wrapper
around the Cloud SDK.
I think Jerome mentioned
the Cloud SDK in his talk.
And the Cloud SDK
is a suite of tools
that we use for managing
everything in the Google Cloud
Platform.
In this case, bdutil will deploy
the Hadoop cluster for us.
It will create some
of those instances
then configure them with
the Hadoop software.
It also installs and
configures the GCS connector,
the Google Cloud
Storage connector.
It's also highly
extensible as well.
We can run individual commands
on the nodes as they come up,
or we can also run
scripts as well.
That's what bdutil is.
That's the util we used when
we looked at the demo earlier.
I'd like to go back to
the demo now, if possible.
Just briefly.
OK, so.
OK, it failed.
Why has it failed?
Sorry.
Really, honestly.
So the few times I run
it up there, it was fine.
And it failed in that one.
OK, I don't know
why it's failed.
Do I care?
I'm going to spend a
very short amount of time
looking at the debug file.
Because I want to
know why it failed.
But we won't get hung up
on this, we'll continue.
Because we can continue.
In the face of adversity,
we always continue.
See, you find it funny.
It's me, I'm falling
apart on the stage.
OK.
You're not telling me much here.
A backend error.
OK, well that's very useful.
OK.
So this script is
highly reliable,
but maybe needs a
little bit more work.
OK, so, can we go back
to the slides, please?
OK, so if you were a
room full of data--
this is a room full
of data scientists.
Are you all data scientists?
Anybody not a data scientist?
Obviously, there's quite
a lot of you, right?
If this was a room full
of data scientists,
I'd be talking about big data.
But let's not get
hung up on that term
because some people find
that kind of difficult
to get their head around.
Maybe, oh, big data,
that's not really for me.
We're just going to
be talking about data,
so let's forget about
that term, apart
from giving it a
quick definition.
Big data is effectively a
data set or a collection
of data sets that are either
too computational or too
large to be handled by
what would be called
traditional data
processing techniques.
I guess today's data processing
techniques in the future
will be traditional
ones as well.
But what it's really
become in reality
is an approach to data
analysis that just would not
be possible with those
older, more traditional data
processing techniques.
I really like this comic strip.
Outside in the world,
we have flying cars.
Imagine what it
takes to coordinate
a bunch of flying cars.
We have personalized
offers being made to a guy
called John Anderson.
We have the management of
traffic flow throughout a city
center, making sure
that people could
be guided to the
appropriate parking spaces.
All of these are big data
problems being solved.
And inside of the
office, there's
an exec guy talking
to his minions.
So I did minions in this sort.
So, OK.
We haven't really got
a bet on or anything
that we can mention
minions in each talk,
but they seem to come
up everywhere nowadays.
The exec guy doesn't
really get it.
He's not ignorant or
anything like that.
It just hasn't hit him yet about
how important this stuff is.
And it's really is important.
And that's why we're
having this talk today.
I just really like
this comic strip.
So some more examples of
gaining insight into data.
Personalised insights
into your customer base
is extremely important.
And I imagine in North
America, like in the UK,
you have grocery stores,
loyalty cards, and other stores
as well, I guess.
All of the big stores
have loyalty cards
which can track your
activities and make
you special offers
at certain points.
Things like in App purchases,
Points of Sale offers.
Another interesting one,
you go into to a bank
to make some query
into your account,
the bank teller brings
up your details,
and the screen also
tells them about things
that might be
interesting to you given
your current financial
circumstances,
and he pitches them to you.
User retention activities
are also extremely important.
For games particularly,
things that have a pattern
based usage.
Where you could use the game
for a certain period of time
and then stop using
it completely.
And if we're monetizing that
game, on the usage of the game,
we want people to
use the game more.
So we can actually analyze
the way people interact
with the game and make decisions
based on somebody's interaction
and to when to make
them free offers.
Those kind of things.
Things that might
make them continue
to engage them in
the game for longer
than they would
have done normally.
Predicting health problems.
We've done this before at
Google with identifying patterns
of searches for flu,
predicting flu epidemics.
Optimization of
websites where analytics
is extremely
important these days.
That's a big data problem.
It's solved by things
like Google Analytics.
And then there's things like
enabling future breakthroughs
in biology and medicine,
which we'll come back to.
And finally, my favorite
one, which is autonomous
traffic lights and flying cars.
So I want traffic lights to
make decisions themselves rather
than be red.
And no cars, no traffic.
I want them to say,
ah, there's no traffic.
I can turn to green
and let me go.
That's a problem I'm
really determined
to solve in my lifetime.
So if anybody wants a job.
So now that we've looked
at the big picture,
let's talk about a
specific application
to the Google Cloud Platform
because we're a data problem.
So for this, we're
going to need to walk
through a specific example.
And we saw a few of them
in the previous slide.
There are many.
There are probably an infinite
number of data problems
we could look at.
So we had to choose
one specifically.
And we have chosen one that's
specifically about genomics.
And the Google genomics team,
who were formed, I think,
in April.
They're busy making tools that
will be used by life scientists
to really handle the incoming
flood of genomic data.
And genomic data is
huge on it's own,
but we also have
a huge population.
So we'll have a huge
data set to mine
to find information out from.
This ultimately will
enable future breakthroughs
in biology and medicine.
The scientists
working with this data
know what they want to do it.
They just want it to be easy.
And this probably resonates
a little bit with you.
Where you probably have
some good idea about what
you would like to do with
data that your organization
generates.
Bu you just need the tools that
would make it very easy to do
and very fast to do.
So at the intersection of
data science and life science
there are discoveries and
breakthroughs to be made.
And in that particular area
of science, maybe things
that could change the
game for us as a race.
But you're probably not
in the genomics business.
And I know I've
said this already.
Is there anybody
in the audience who
is in the genomics business?
AUDIENCE: I am.
MANDY WAITE: So
we've already spoken.
I knew.
I was going to
ask this question,
I didn't expect anyone
to put their hands up.
But we have somebody who is in
the genomics business, which
is fantastic.
However, if you're
not a data scientist,
your particular
business, no doubt,
is also a complex affair.
And it requires
specialized knowledge.
And you're probably an
expert in your own domain.
So no doubt there
are insights to be
gained at the intersection
of your business
with data science.
So the first question we need
to ask is, where is your data?
And most companies have a
lot of data lying around.
Usually one or usually
more operational databases.
The examples I'm going
to be showing you
are from the Personal
Genome Project.
I'm not sure if it's anything
you guys are familiar with,
but this is what we're
going to be looking at,
the Personal Genome Project.
So the PGP is effectively
creating a freely available
resource, a scientific
resource, that brings together
three types of data.
Genomic data, environmental,
and human trait data.
So that's information about
the genetic makeup of a person.
The environments in which
they were brought up in,
in which they live in, and which
they work in from day to day.
And also, traits
that they exhibit.
Do they have diabetes?
Did their mother
have a brain tumor?
Are they susceptible
to broken limbs?
Do they have green hair?
Or do they have yellow skin
and look something like him?
Oh, you don't see him.
I'm showing a picture of a
minion, but you can't see him.
So let's just go
back to that slide.
Hello, go back.
So this is a data set we're
going to be working with.
And we have some genomic data
stored in Google Cloud Storage,
which we're going to be using.
So, no matter where
your data is now,
there are usually two things
that are true about it.
The first is it's
not in a place where
it's best or most
easy to analyze.
And it's also probably
not in the right format.
So this brings us to
extract, transform, and load,
which is a process of taking
data in one place in one format
and moving it to another
place in a different format.
Now, this might be fairly
straightforward and fairly
simple to do on a
small amount of data.
But what if you
have a lot of data?
What happens if we have
a huge amount of data,
so much it will overwhelm the
tools you have available to you
today?
That's what we're going
to be talking about,
and that's what this dump
truck represents here.
So let's talk about our
data in more detail.
We're not going to
go into the demo yet.
But we have all this data
stored in Google Cloud Storage.
We have a tool here we're using
called gsutil to actually list
that data.
We can actually
effectively interact
with this data stored
in cloud storage
as if it's local just by
using this tool, gsutil ls.
And we can see we have a couple
of files listed there, only two
of them.
There are 175 files in
the data set in total,
representing 174
participants of the PGP
and one duplicate
for some reason.
Each file is about
2.3 gigabytes in size
and has 17 million rows.
They are identified
exclusively in the file
name with a identifier.
In this case, we
hu011C57 and hu016B28.
These are individual
participants
in the Genome Project.
One problem with that is that
data, that participant ID,
is not in the data in the file.
So we have 17 million rows
of data, and none of it
contains information about
who that participant is.
So that's a problem we want
to solve with our demo.
So can we switch
back to the demo?
So this the list of all
the files, the 175 of them
that we have.
And I'm just going to
quickly run a script.
But I can't.
I have to kind of juggle
between going back to the slides
and going back from the demo.
So I'm just going to run
this script on this file now.
And I'm going to
pipe that to more.
And this is taking that
file that we had before.
And it's prepended,
added a column
to the data set which
represents the participant
ID, the ID of the participant
in the Genome Project.
And this what we want to output.
What we could do
at this point is
we could actually pipe
that out to a file
or redirect that out to a file.
But we have 175
files, and there's
17 million rows of
data in that data set.
It could take a long
time to process one file.
Well, how are we going
to process 175 of them?
So can you go back to
the slides, please?
We can run that
script on one file,
but what happens when we want to
run it across all 175 of them?
So this is where
Mapreduce comes in.
In this case, we can run
a command on the thing
that we identified as a NameNode
earlier, the master machine.
If our cluster was up and
running-- unfortunately,
our cluster isn't
up and running,
so I can't interact
with it-- we would
run the command,
a Hadoop command,
and pass in some parameters.
One would be where
the input data was.
And that's the third line in
this command string, the lower
command string, minus input.
Then we would specify
the mapper script.
This is the script that would
be used for the map step.
Then we would also specify
the number of reduce tasks.
In this case it's none.
We're not doing any
kind of reducing.
Our map script is very simple.
We need to remove
the duplicate data
and add that column right
at the start of each row.
And then we need to say
but we want to output it.
And we're going output it
to Google Cloud Storage
in a bucket called
big-data-roadshow/output.
So if I were running
the demo now--
and I can't because the cluster
didn't deploy correctly--
I would submit that job.
And we would see
in the console we
have 20 nodes available to
us to actually run the job.
And then we would
drill into the job,
and look at the specific
details of the job,
and we would wait
for it to complete.
And this job takes about
5 minutes, 41 seconds.
I would have actually
worked on the 17 file set,
about a tenth of the
original data set, which
would take considerably
less time to run.
And we can see that the map
job, there were 704 of them,
and they completed successfully.
There was nothing to do in the
reduce step, no jobs at all.
And that was successful.
So that has now
processed our data.
It's moved the data from
one place in one format
to another place
in another format.
Exactly what extract,
transform, and load specifies.
So that's good.
So that's more information.
435 gigabytes roughly of data
was processed by the Hadoop job
and takes about 5
and 1/2 minutes.
And 3 million rows of data.
So then we could
delete the cluster.
I would really like
to delete the cluster
because it failed me, didn't
it? [INAUDIBLE] Didn't it?
One thing that never
fails me is BigQuery,
though, so we're going
to talk about BigQuery.
So there is more,
there's always more.
At this point
though, that may be
all you need to do in your data.
And you may be doing
it on a daily basis.
You may be processing your data
from one format in one place
to another format in
a different place.
We do that at
Google all the time,
contrary to popular opinion.
Some people may
actually get that joke,
but others might not.
We still do lots of Mapreduces.
And mapreduces can be a key
part of an organization's data
processing tool kit.
But there is more.
In this stage we want to
actually process the data
and get insight from the data.
So we're going to
use Google BigQuery.
And I think Jerome
mentioned BigQuery already.
BigQuery effectively allows
us to run interactive queries
across massive data sets.
And we're talking about
terabytes of data, billions
and billions of rows of data.
Interactive queries are great
because you can ask questions
of the data and then you
can modify the question
you asked based on the
results you've just seen.
We do this all the time
with our log files.
So we have lots of log
data internally at Google.
We have the internal
version of BigQuery,
which is called Dremel.
We run interactive
queries across the log
files that we have to
see what's going on.
There's no limit on
the amount of data
that you can store and
process in BigQuery.
It's very easy to use.
You don't have to
administer anything.
create a machine.
You don't have to do
the build process here
that failed for us.
You have the machines
available to you
that are needed to
process the data.
We provide those
dynamically, automatically.
It has all of the convenience
of SQL, as we'll see shortly.
It's an API.
BigQuery is an API.
We'll see a console
shortly, but that was just
written on top of the API.
The first one terabyte of data
that you process per month
is free.
It provides a very familiar
database structure.
So you have databases, you
have tables within the data,
within the database.
Data management is very easy,
and it has the opportunity
to import data atomically
very, very quickly.
There are various
methodologies you
can use to get
data into BigQuery.
So can we jump back
to the demo, please?
So this is the BigQuery console.
Can everybody read that?
OK.
Anybody not read it?
OK, cool, excellent.
OK, so, we have plenty of public
data sets that are available
and sample data sets as well.
So BigQuery samples of data
sets we can play around with.
We have one called-- I
can't see it completely
there-- wikimedia_pageviews.
And this is Wikimedia pages that
were viewed on a given date.
And it's all sharded
into several tables.
Here we see them by date and
go all the way down to 201207
We haven't got any
later data than that,
but we go up to 201207.
So we have sharded data
by month, effectively,
for these pageviews
in Wikimedia.
And what I can do is
I can load up a query.
And I can zoom in on my
query, make it a bit bigger.
And I can run this query.
So basically, this is BigQuery.
It looks very much like SQL,
if anybody's used SQL already.
We're going to be selecting the
title and the number of views,
or we're going to sum the number
of views for a particular page.
We're going to do it across
a number of those tables.
So we can actually do this
across multiple tables,
one query across
multiple tables.
We're going to add
some where clauses.
The important ones
are language equals
en and the regex
expression here.
Something beginning with G,
has an O in it, and ends in E.
Can anybody think of a
word that might fit that?
Not sure.
Group by title.
And views, order by
views descending.
There's a little bug in this.
I don't how I ended up with
that, but it still works.
So I'm not going to
worry about it too much.
Come back to here.
I can click on this green arrow
down here and see how much
data that will process.
That's going to process 507
gigabytes when it's run.
It also tells me that the
query I'm running is valid.
So we get one terabyte of
data of free per month.
This is going to use half
my quota up in a month.
And obviously I've run
it a couple of times
already just to practice to
make sure it was working.
So I'm already over the top
in terms of using my quota.
But don't do this
unless you want
to spend money because
it's a big data set.
So let's come back to here.
I'm going to run that query.
We go down here where
it says query running.
And it takes probably
about 12, 30 seconds.
If there's any problems
with the timing,
it's because of it's
trying to contact
the job that's running remotely.
And that could be impacted
by the Wi-Fi speeds
and various other things.
So we processed that.
507 gigabytes processed
in 18.4 seconds.
And we can see there.
Sometimes it's hard to
play with the real estate.
Ah, Google!
Of course, I didn't
think about that.
And back in those days,
Gotye were famous.
Again, that's another
joke that many of you
might-- Google Chrome
is also quite popular.
And again, sometimes when
I'm running this demo
I'm do it in
different languages.
But I run it in France, I'll
do it with fr as language,
and we'll see other
interesting things.
And you always have
to run it beforehand
to make sure nothing
rude comes up.
Well, you do.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
OK, so we need to
load up our data.
So imagine the data we created
from our mapreduce job.
We can load it up here.
We'll enter the path to
our cloud storage bucket.
We'll say it's a
CSV separated file.
And we'll click Next, specify
the schema for the data,
and we can import that
data into BigQuery.
Fortunately for
us, that's already
been done for us
because we have--
and we'll just close
this down a little bit
and go to display project.
Big Gene.
And you can do this
yourself as well.
So you can go to BigQuery, you
can add this data set yourself
to your own BigQuery set up.
I'll just zoom in a
little bit on that.
We have three tables
in our PGP database,
cgi_variants,
phenotypes, and variants.
And we care about this
one, cgi_variants.
So we can select
that and then we
could look at information
about the schema.
Bear with me a second.
It's hard to know what
I'm scrolling here.
And this has lots of information
that's genomic related.
Remember, all this stuff could
apply equally to your own data.
This just happens to
be a genomic data.
So back to the slides, please.
I'm going to run out of
time very quickly, see.
So we can actually run
a query to work out
how many rows are
in that data set.
I'm not going to do that now
because we're short on time.
But we have, from the
row count done there,
about three million rows.
And then we had to ask, what
question do we want to solve?
What problem do we want to ask
of this data set that we have?
So apparently there's
been some press
about a study that
effectively identified
that a variant, a
genetic variant,
may have something to
do with intelligence.
And that that, according
to this headline anyway,
is actually related
to longevity.
In fact, they've
given it to mice,
and it's made the
mice live longer.
It's also made them smarter.
I'm not quite sure
how they measure that.
I guess they have these little
mazes that they run around.
I guess you can tell
how smart a mouse is.
It sounds like a pretty
good deal, right?
So let's find out
how many participants
of the Human Genome Project,
Personal Genome Project,
have this variant.
We could also enter this
variant name by name.
It's called RS9536314.
But variants are a little
bit like asteroids.
There's so many of
them, they don't even
bother to name most of them.
Until one of them
is interesting.
Then they give it
some scientific name
like RS956314, which is great.
If you search for
RS956314, you'll
get this page, which tells
you it's in chromosome number
13, which is down
there at the bottom.
So we want to search
chromosome 13 for that variant.
We're going to do
this is in BigQuery.
What we're going to find out is
that we have these two columns.
One of them is sized badly
because of the projector.
Allele1Seq, allele2Seq.
If they are both empty, then
they don't have the variant.
If one is G and
one is T, there's
a variant in one allele.
If they are G and G, both
alleles have the variant.
If they're question marks,
it means we're not sure.
We don't have that
information within the data.
So let's run that in BigQuery.
Can you go back to the demo?
So here's my query.
We're going to be selecting
things like the sample ID,
this is the participant ID.
The chromosome.
The two alleles that we're
really interested in.
We also are going to be
looking for a specific place
because the list that we
looked at earlier actually
identified it.
It was in a specific place
within the chromosome.
And we're going to be searching
the cgi_variant table.
Does that make sense?
OK, we're so going to
be looking chromosome
13, at a specific location,
for those variants.
So I come back
out, run the query,
and that doesn't take
very long to run, I think.
It's run already.
So 5.7 seconds elapsed.
117 gigabytes processed.
Now you'll notice that's
less than the total size
of the data.
But that's because we're not
looking at the entire data set.
So BigQuery uses
a columnar format
for storing data
instead of rows.
So when it reads data, it
only loads in the columns
that you're actually
interested in.
So that's only a small part of
the data set, as in this case.
So we're only looking at a
small section of the data,
but we're looking at every row.
So in terms of results,
we have-- again,
BigQuery getting in the way with
its-- We have lots of options.
We have 174 rows processed here.
We can see one immediately
that's actually
got that chromosome in one
allele, which is great, OK.
That's told us what
we do have patterns.
We do have participants that
do have that genetic variant.
We wanted to find out
how many of them had.
So let's modify our query.
And this time, I'll go
back to my queue history
rather than typing it in,
because you've already
seen my typing's lousy.
And we'll run an aggregate
query across that same data set.
And I'll zoom in.
In this case, we're looking
for pretty much the same data,
but we're counting the number
of sample IDs that match.
We're looking the same place.
And we're going to group
by it and order by it.
So we can do aggregate
queries with BigQuery as well.
So I'm going to run that query.
And come down here,
query running.
11.5 seconds elapsed,
117 gigabytes processed.
Resize this.
And we can see 135 participants
don't have that variant.
32 of them have it in one
of their rows and 5 of them
have it in both.
Lucky people.
They're smart, and they're
going to live long.
I want some of that.
So when they do genetic
therapy, I want this one.
So can you go back to
the slides, please?
So these are the results.
We saw this already.
They're just there in
case anything falls apart.
So basically what we've
done here is effectively,
we've gone from data to meaning.
We've had to decide
what kind of questions
we want to ask because we want
to have the data in the best
possible format to answer them.
We don't always know what
questions we want to ask,
but we always have a good
idea of what kind of question
we want to ask.
Then we're going to
say, where is our data?
Is it in the right place?
Is it in the right format?
In this example, we've taken
data stored in cloud storage.
We've done an extract,
transform, and load.
And we've stored
it into BigQuery.
Once into BigQuery, we've
actually run queries over it
to gain insight into that data.
Now we could do
this interactively.
We could do this
as much as we like.
We could also program the whole
thing and do it automatically.
The last couple of things.
Coming soon, we have Cloud
Dataflow, Cloud Pub/Sub.
These are really important
changes in the way we do data.
We have Google I/O talks that
will introduce you to them.
I can't do them justice
here, so talking about them
would be pointless.
We also have the ability
to build Apache Spark
clusters using the bdutil.
And spark is in memory,
effectively, cluster.
It is much, much
faster than anything
we've seen today
in terms of Hadoop,
not in terms of BigQuery.
And resources as well.
I'll leave that slide
up while I bow out.
But these are the
resources you can
use to access to give you
more information about what
we talked about today.
So that's pretty much it.
We can talk about this later
if you have any more questions.
But thank you very much.